[Music]  has this ever happened to you you're  acting like a drunken jackass at your  company Christmas party hello why are  you talking to this loser when you could  be banging me in the supply closet what  do you say you're gonna get fired I  don't want to get fired then you have  two options one stop being a drunken  jackass that's not gonna happen  or two call us at Brenton a hole the  only service that sends over a drunken  [ __ ] even more obnoxious than you to  distract others from your awful behavior  that sounds great your rent in a hole  will arrive quickly and already drunk  laughs we'll get right to work with  unsolicited come-ons  jugs alert I get lost in your packs  unwelcome karaoke there's no thee but a  goody  Restless decorations on his crotch and  bursting into unprovoked tears I've got  a doll home  not even your boss will be safe you're  fired  all right you get a raise  how'd you like to seal me up in the copy  room oh yes  thanks for in an a-hole  [Applause]